[Music]
welcome back dr nash has been helping
clients all across the valley
lose weight but some of our success
stories go far beyond weight loss
take a look at dominic working with dr
nash i lost 70 pounds in three and a
half months and reversed my type 2
diabetes and i feel great
dr nash that is unbelievable on multiple
levels first off we'll get to the weight
loss in a second but the thing that
jumps out to me
is you reversed dominic's diabetes his
type 2 diabetes
how did you do that when he was only 20
years old he found out that he was
pre-diabetic and this is way too common
in our country
and then either not paying attention to
that or doing things on his own
five years later he blossomed into
full-blown type 2 diabetes and that's
when he decided that he wanted to not
only control it
he wanted to reverse it and in order to
reverse
diabetes it means we have to go inside
the body find out what's wrong
and correct issues like hormone problems
inflammation
and fatty liver it can all be reversed
through natural means they can only be
controlled with drugs
and that's how we're able to get him out
of that diabetic situation
when you first met dominic and you
started him on a program did you
think he was going to lose a hundred
pounds i mean you see this happening
with his way his lifestyle was or maybe
how he approached his diet did you see
those results coming
i'm always optimistic whenever a client
comes to me but i'm always like a
reserve
optimism i really want them to grasp
just how much they can change their life
with this program but none of them all
do
he took my program and floored with it
how come some doctors they seem to
manage the symptoms which which works
but
you're reversing it how i mean how are
you doing this i believe
reversing the type 2 diabetes means you
got to get a little bit more involved
with the person
help them understand how the choices
that they're making are impacting that
diabetes give them the hope that they
can reverse it
and not just kind of shuffle them
through an endless cycle of blood work
doctor visits and different medications
like we just keep seeing people getting
more and more medications for diabetes
piling on some bad information on what
they can do to get control of it and
reverse it and i think that's the
difference is we got to get them real
information to reverse it
are these results that we see from you
are they typical with your clients
they are typical with my clients but
they are not typical so what that means
is if you're trying to do it on your own
the likelihood that you're going to get
these same kind of results are low
because again the information is
confusing
you've got to get the right information
the right steps for your body and then
you've got to
follow what i say that you need to do in
order for you to see these kinds of
results but when you do
the results come every time i love it
and dr nashville i also love this you
always have a great special for our las
vegas now viewers
what do you have for us this week yes so
normally when you make an appointment to
see me and we do the evaluation
it's about 97 to get that done but
whenever i get to go on las vegas now
with jc of course i'm always going to
bring a special offer
so i have about 10 spots available
through the website that we're showing
on the screen
where you can get it at 90 percent off
only 9.97
there is only 10 spots available they're
all on the internet
once you book your spot it's gone so
make sure that you get over there and
get that done as soon as possible